[Musique]
le temps qu'ils passent les années qui
passent pour vous c'est un problème
non pas du tout non pas du tout je n'y
pense pas si l'on parle tous ces justes
déroulement est normal de la vie n'était
pas du tout mais ça vous inquiète est ce
que vous y pensez que dans un temps car
vous vous ne pouvez pas ignorer que vous
avez été un mythe toutes les jeunes
filles souhaitais vous ressemblez tous
les jeunes gens étaient amoureux de vous
c'est incontestable est-ce que vous en
avez été consciente de ça pas tellement
non pas tellement nous dit beaucoup
maintenant mais c'est vrai que j'en
étais pas tellement consciente
7 ce mythe vous ne vous a jamais ça vous
a jamais effleuré vous n'avez jamais été
je suis très surprise de ça mais non
mais vous voulez dire quoi non ce qui
met ce qui m'impressione c'est quand on
disait ça parce que comprenait pas
pourquoi je les représente et hamit moi
je me trouve très normal et très simple
et très timide et inquiète alors ça me
semblait toujours un petit peu
extraordinaire en tout cas vous êtes
quelqu'un qui n'avait jamais cessé
d'être actif très active vous me disiez
à l'instant calais au théâtre tous les
soirs c'est un petit peu difficile car
au fond vous êtes quelqu'un qui aimait
aussi beaucoup la vie de famille un
jeune beaucoup rester chez moi je veux
dire que quand je ne travaille pas je ne
sors pas beaucoup
j'adore regarder la télévision bien
allongé bien confortable et je trouve ça
vraiment merveilleux il ya des gens qui
aiment beaucoup sortir moi non et
pourtant vous êtes débordante d'activité
car je suis de vendée n'a joui vous
jouez oui j'ai tourné pendant quatre
mois et je jouais en même temps depuis
mois de septembre et ça c'est très dur
[Musique]